welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid I was having a conversation with
awkward em recently about some of the
weird ways that animals reproduce and it
got me a little curious so I made a list
for you this is Nick loose its top 10
craziest animal sex list of science of
2013 okay maybe that's a little long for
a title how about that top 10 craziest
animal sex list of science yeah still a
little long we could go with crazy
animal sex or maybe even just sex you
know leave some things up to the
imagination you already spoiled
everyone's imagination with the first
title yeah I guess you're right
whatever I ranked the list from least
crazy to most crazy let's do this 10
giraffes the male giraffe will nudge the
females private area to encourage peeing
yeah I said peeing
then the male giraffe smells the pee to
check for fertility if she's ready he'll
try to straddle her which as you can
imagine can be a bit awkward with their
body shape now I in the hippos how do
male hippos attract mates by filling in
poop everywhere they do it even when the
females aren't there hey how did you get
my teleporter all right so it's more
likely they're flinging poop to show off
to other males it's called the power
display human males do it too actual
studies have shown that the more males
that are sitting at a table together the
more likely it is that they're gonna
have their cell phones out too anyway
the display just inadvertently attracts
females the resulting sex will occur
with the female underwater for most of
the experience luckily they're good at
holding their breath eight porcupines
when the male porcupine finds a female
he pees all over her from about 6 feet
away if she squeals and moves away then
she's not ready if she is ready she'll
encourage him to come a little closer
where she'll make it wait until he's too
exhausted to do it anymore
if at that point she hasn't had enough
she'll go find another male to finish
the job
7 honeybees male honeybees otherwise
known as drones are born for the sole
purpose of breeding when the Queen is
ready she flies out of the hive the
male's will fly close to her and attempt
to mount her midair now here's the real
kicker upon completion the successful
male's penis explodes and is ripped from
his body remaining in the Queen that
male will then fall to his death due to
excessive trauma sick
flatworms these guys are hermaphrodites
meaning they have both male and female
parts these worms actually fence with
their penises to decide who will be the
female it's pretty epic actually five
garden snails these are also
hermaphrodites like the flatworms
but they're a little more diplomatic
about things their sex parts are in
their necks and each of them gets their
female parts fertilized by the others
male parts however before climax
they shoot mucus covered darts into each
other the cotton love darts the mucus on
these darts helps their sperm survive as
long as possible unfortunately they're
not always good at aiming so sometimes
they accidentally kill their mates for
banana slugs these slugs are called
banana slugs for obvious reasons when it
comes to sex though they have to choose
their mates very carefully if their
penis is too large for their mate they
get stuck and they run the risk of the
other slug chewing it off to get away
ouch three the earthworm might also
known as his stoma merchant histy oma
Mirchi hissed it it's right there this
is a mite that lives and breeds in the
cocoons of earthworms the female mite
doesn't have time to wait around for a
male to show up so she gives birth to
several of them herself a sexually it's
called parthenogenesis those males grow
up to fertile adults and only a couple
of days at that point the female
immediately mates with them before they
die of old age and she is now pregnant
with females - angler fish these
deep-sea fish are insanely crazy the one
you're seeing right now is a female and
she happens to be very adept at luring
in food with her dangling global male
anglerfish on the other hand are much
smaller and not very good at finding
food what they are good at is finding a
female when they do find one they bite
her side and latch on like parasites
those males will no longer have to worry
about finding food because their body's
at internal organs slowly fuse with the
females and they just live off her
bodily fluids now appearing almost like
an extra fin on the female the male's
provide an easy source of sperm for her
to use whenever she's ready to give
birth WTF nature and lastly the number
one craziest of them all bedbugs the
female bedbug has parts for birthing but
not for sex when a female is ready for
breeding she finds a nun
suspecting sleeping victim and drinks
her fill of blood she then returns to
the rest of the bedbugs and the male's
violently rape her abdomen with their
sharp penises peni penises
it's called traumatic insemination the
female will likely heal from this give
birth and repeat this process several
times in her life like I said crazy so
what's the craziest mating habit you've
ever heard of please share in the
comments and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy
you
female horses almost made this list if
they get pregnant from one male but are
around tomb and the other males they'll
go have sex with all the males that they
can why you may ask because males have a
tendency to kill offspring that isn't
theirs and the female would rather the
male's be a little unsure about whose is
whose that's why most bands of wild
horses only have one or two males it
only really becomes a problem when we
forced it on domesticated horses